it is incredible how people just do not
seem to understand how incentives work
so you have joe biden out there saying
things like we need to add free years of
the federal government needs to who
thinks in this day and age
that 12 years of eduma culture mission
is enough we need 14 years
maybe 16. we need two preschool
and two of junior college because my
wife
dr jamakalu she
she says junior college is good well
here's the thing
when you give people free crap for no
reason
they spend the money on stupid crap okay
case in point this is from the wall
street journal today
financially hobbled for life the elite
master's degrees that don't pay off
colombia and other top universities push
master's programs that fail to generate
enough income for grads to keep up with
six-figure federal loans
so many people are asking how could
colombia push such programs
my question is why is the federal
government subsidizing this garbage
here is the piece from melissa corn and
andrea fuller
recent film program graduates of
columbia university who took out federal
student loans
had a median debt of 181 thousand
dollars
yet two years after earning their
masters half of the borrowers were
making
less than thirty thousand dollars a year
okay so here's the question what bank
would subsidize this
seriously if you're a banker and
somebody walks in they're like
man i like avant-garde film and
i want to go to columbia u
where i'm going to learn about lens
flare
and i'll do all of that all it will cost
you is 180 thousand dollars
and the banker's like okay what's your
collateral like i don't have collateral
my free spirit is my collateral
so the banker would laugh and then throw
you out of his office by contrast if you
walked into a banker's office and you
said hey
i'm getting a law degree from harvard
law school and i need some money to
borrow
the bank would be like great average
median outcome
of uh is is like a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year working at a big
law firm for a few years to pay off
those student loans pretty good shot i
get the money back
that's how it would work in private
industry the banker would look at you
look at your record look at your credit
history
look at what you're trying to get the
degree in and then the banker would be
like okay that's either worth the risk
or it's not worth the risk and student
loans are particularly risky because
unlike a mortgage
where there's natural collateral right
you don't pay the mortgage and the
company just come the bank comes and
seizes your house
there is no collateral with student
loans if you don't pay off your student
loans
nothing happens it wrecks your credit
but that's about all
they can't come and repossess your leg
or something they can't come and
repossess the degree on your wall
so that means that people would be
pretty cautious about extending lines of
credit
so that you could go major in russian
cinema
okay but the federal government has no
such issues the federal government's
like hey taxpayer dollars
you want to go major in soft core
swedish pornography at columbia
university
do it man broaden your horizons college
man
master's degrees and then these people
can't pay back their loans like oh my
god why can't i pay
because you took out two hundred
thousand dollars in loans to go to
colombia's film school
i hate to break it to all of you budding
artists out there but you might want to
get a career that pays you
the number of people go to film school
who end up as christopher nolan is
christopher nolan
okay like this this basic weird i follow
your dreams
what if your dreams are just kind of
dumb what if your dreams don't don't
take stock of any reality i will give
you an example
so my father was a musician and my
father went to
berkeley school of music and then my dad
went out to hollywood and he tried to
get a job in the music sphere
and he did some stuff he wrote a couple
of movies nothing major
and it never just panned out that is the
common story from berkeley school of
music so
when i was growing up i was a pretty
good violinist i i
started playing when i was five i was
practicing like two three hours a day
when i was in my early teens
and then there came a point where it was
like i can either try and make this a
career
or i can go into some field where i
actually have a chance of making money
and my mom who had started off as a
secretary at the company where she
began and then she became the vice
president she worked her way all the way
up the chain
she said you know it'd be good it'd be
good for you to go to college and then
go to law school and get a degree in
something where you have a shot at
making money and my dad who'd been a
musician was like yeah that is a good
idea
because it turns out that a dream
that you and your dreams will buy you a
cup of coffee maybe if you are lucky
you actually have to assess risk well
banks certainly have to assess risk
because they're paying with somebody
else's money
the federal government never has to
assess risk because as long as it is
passing you out free money to pursue
your bra dream dude
then you're fine the predictable result
is people take out enormous amounts of
debt to do stupid things and then they
cannot repay the debt and then they go
and about it to the wall street
journal that is that is the predictable
it is like the most predictable
incentive structure
in the history of humanity and everybody
is throwing up their hands like how
could this happen it's colombia's fault
maybe colombia should pay for their
degrees or maybe colombia is responding
to a market incentive
you want to know why the college prices
have been going up so radically over the
course of recent decades
is because the federal government has
been subsidizing loans encouraging
everybody
to go to college employers have been
taking up debate
and then colleges have been responding
by raising their prices because there's
increased demand
end of story the whole system is skewed
and stupid
we'll get to more on why the federal
government should not be subsidizing
student loans in just one second first
let's say that you are a college student
and that you actually are about to
celebrate an excellent summer well you
know what you need
you need greatest of all wireless
earbuds i'm talking about
raycon's indeed check this out right
here these
babies these wireless earbuds start at
half the price of other
premium audio brands raycon earbuds give
you six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass
more compact design for a comfortable
noise isolating fit raycon offers their
wireless earbuds in a range of fun
colors and patterns they've got a
variety of fit options
no dangling wires they're incredibly
comfortable because again you can
customize them to fit your ear
properly the company was co-founded by
ray j celebrities like snoop dogg brandy
and i we are all obsessed with ray cons
now that is an interesting
dinner party plus raycon has a 45 day
free
return policy i'll be taking these
raikons to the beach while i'm hanging
out
with my kids click the link in the
description box or go to buyrecon.com
shapiro yt to get 15 off your raycon
purchase i mean take a look at how easy
it is
to make these babies work you open up
the box you take out
the raicons you put them in your ears
you're good to go you're done it's just
that easy
raycons are great go check them out
right now by raycon
dot com shapiro yt get 15 off your
raycon purchase today so according to
the wall street journal
the columbia program offers the most
extreme example of how elite
universities in recent years
have awarded thousands of master's
degrees that don't provide graduates
enough early career earnings to begin
paying down their federal student loans
according to a wall street journal
analysis of education department data
recent columbia firm alumni had the
highest debt compared with earnings
among graduates of any major university
masters program in the us the journal
found
the new york city's university is among
the world's most prestigious schools its
11.3 billion
endowment ranks it the nation's 8th
wealthiest private school
for years faculty staff and students
have appealed unsuccessfully to
administrators to tap that wealth to aid
more graduate students
according to current and formal faculty
and administrators and dozens of
students
taxpayers will be on the hook for
whatever is left unpaid
why because politicians should not be
handing out loans
when politicians hand out loans they
typically give money to people they
believe
will it will benefit politically that's
it they hand out money to people they
think are going to be political allies
viewered by the aura of degrees from top
plate institutions many masters students
at universities across the us took on
debt beyond what their pay would support
the journal analysis of federal data on
borrowers found at columbia such
students graduated from programs
including history
social work and architecture no no
who could have foreseen that if you give
somebody a 200 000
loan so they can go study social work at
columbia they're not going to be
repaying that anytime soon
wait you're telling me yeah i can't
believe this you're telling me
that if somebody goes and majors in
queer history
at columbia in a master's program
they're not going to be paying back that
200 000
federally subsidized loan who could have
foreseen such a thing if only
there was some market mecha if only
there were a mechanism
let's call it the free market in which a
banker
would actually sit and do an actuarial
assessment of your risk natural rl
assessment
and look at your risk and say maybe this
degree is worth money and maybe this
degree is not worth money
i don't think it's worth money no and
then you'd cry
oh that you'd cry to the heavens oh why
can't i get
my money for that deeply desired degree
in lesbian dance theory why why oh gods
why okay and then you would go and get a
regular job and you'd
live a happier life but nope we've
decided that it's the federal
government's job to subsidize your dumb
dream
columbia university president lee
bollinger said the education department
data in the journal analysis can't fully
assess salary prospects because it only
covers earnings and loan repayments two
years after graduation
nevertheless he said this is not what we
want it to be at nyu
graduates with a master's degree in
publishing borrowed a median 116
thousand dollars
and had an annual median income of 42
thousand dollars two years after the
program
the data on recent borrowers showed
again
i'm just i'm shocked at master's degrees
these are the ones we've analyzed so far
film publishing
history and also social work
i can't believe these things aren't
paying off i'm astonished at
northwestern university
half of those who earn degrees in speech
language pathology borrowed 148 000
or more graduates had a median income of
60 grand two years later
graduates at the university of southern
california marriage and family
counseling counseling program
borrowed a median of 124 thousand
dollars half earned 50 grand or less
over the same period
i i'm i'm shocked can't believe it just
can't believe it
by the way the ones that uh are the
worst drama theater arts and stagecraft
at columbia
that is the debt compared to income by
master's degree program
so yeah film video and drama theater art
there's always these two 2am panic
attacks where you're thinking how the
hell am i ever going to pay this off i
said 29 year old zach morrison of
columbia
of new jersey learned a master of fine
arts in film from columbia in 2018
and praised the quality of the program
his grad school loan balance now stands
in nearly 300 000 including accrued
interest
he's been earning between 30 and 50
grand a year from work as a hollywood
assistant and such side gigs as
commercial video production and
photography
i i can't believe it i mean again play
stupid games
win stupid prizes it's just amazing to
me that we're supposed to pretend that
this is a problem with the colleges as
opposed to the entire incentive
structure created
by the federal government subsidizing
garbage loans
like if only we had a history of what
happens
when you subsidize loans to people who
are unlikely to pay them back
let's say in like real estate like let's
say that there were a bunch of borrowers
who
really could not afford particular home
loans and then
you had federally subsidized programs
that were designed to make sure that
those people got loans we can call those
loans like subprime loans because they
were not high quality they were subprime
so you know let's let's call them
subprime mortgages
what would happen if we did that for
like a decade would that have any
deleterious consequences
you know when you screw up the incentive
structures you get
exactly what you are not aiming for
namely you hurt the very people you are
trying to help
as all liberal programs do shocker
shocker
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content